انسحبت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي للمخيم
جنين بعد عمليه اقتحام نفذتها بذريعه
البحث عن ناشطين في حركه حماس وتخللت
العمليه الاسرائيليه التي قالت تل ابيب
انها حققت اهدافها باعتقال العناصر
المطلوبه تخللت اشتباكات مع فصائل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه التي اكدت ان
مقاتليها افشلوا مخطط جيش الاحتلال للنيل
من فعاليتها في الضفه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه
مسارات
ما السياقات الامنيه والسياسيه لتصيد قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
اجراءاتها ضد الفلسطينيين في الضفه
الغربيه وما دلالات استمرار سياسه
الاقتحامات بالرغم من وجود تفاهمات امنيه
مسبقه بين السلطه واسرائيل بوقف المداهمات
للمدن والقرى الفلسطينيه
وكيف نفسر الاجراءات الاسرائيليه في
فلسطين وعلى حدودها كالاعلان عن بناء
السياج الامني على طول الحدود مع الاردن
بعد الانتهاء من سياج امني على الحدود مع
مصر ومن رسائل وفي اي اتجاه
وما هي خيارات السلطه الفلسطينيه في
التعامل مع الموقف الراهن في ظل الفروقات
الاسرائيليه للتفاهمات الامنيه السابقه
وما مواقف الدول العربيه التي رعت تلك
التفاهمات وما خيارات فصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في الضفه الغربيه في المرحله
المقبله بعدما شهدته من ارتفاع وتيره
العمليات المسلحه ضد اسرائيل في الشهور
الماضيه
[موسيقى]
اذا مستخدما عشرات الاليات العسكريه
والقناصه تم نشرهم على اسطح المنازل شن
الجيش الاسرائيلي ما وصفه بالعمليه الخاصه
معلنا ان الهدف منها هو اعتقال مطلوبين
ينتمون لحركه حماس
عمليه رصدتها المقاومه وتصدت لها في
اشتباكات وصفت بالعنيفه اسفرت عن وقوع
اصابات وكذلك عن اسقاط مسيره اسرائيليه
الجيش الاسرائيلي وقال ان المطلوبين هم
عناصر من المقاومه الفلسطينيه كانوا قد
حاولوا اطلاق صواريخ محليه الصنع باتجاه
مستوطنات اسرائيليه
وفيما وصف الجيش الاسرائيلي عمليته
بالناجحه اكدت حركه حماس ان المقاومه
افشلت مخططا اسرائيليا للنيل منها مشدده
على ان الاعتقالات لن تفت من عضوضها وتعد
هذه العمليه العسكريه الاسرائيليه اول
مداهمه اسرائيليه لمخيم جنين منذ استشهادي
13 فلسطينيا ومقتل اسرائيلي خلال عمليه
عسكريه الاسرائيليه في تموز يوليو الماضي
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من القدس
قالوا لنا افيتار المستشار السابق للشؤون
العربيه في وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه قبل
ان يلتحق بعده بنا ضيوفنا الاخرون اهلا بك
اهلا
عودون على بدء ككل مره اذا جنين واكياس
وليس كيس الذرائع
لحكومه نتنياهو لا ينفذ ماذا عن هذه المره
برايك
مساء الخير بدي اول اشي في البدايه بدي
اتذكر المشاهدين انه قضيه مخيم جنين هي مش
قضيه اللي بلشت او بدات في حكومات نتنيه
ان احنا بنحكي على
شمال الدافئ خاصه منطقه جنين الكوبا وكمان
مخيم جنين في في هذه في النص المنطقه انه
الاشكاليات هناك بلشت او بدات قبل سنتين
تقريبا
اليوم اليوم للاسف ما انتهت المشكله في
هذه المنطقه نحن بنحكي على كم مواضيع اول
شيء في تعاون بين المنظمات الفلسطينيه
تعون الشغل المشترك مستمر بنفتح وجهاد
واسلامي وحماس داخل المخيم
ثاني شيء مع الاسف كمان كانت فرصه
لسلطه الفلسطينيه انه تدخل مع الاجهزه
الامنيه للمخيم وراح تشتغل داخل المخيم
لحد اليوم السلطه اخذت الفرصه بس خارج
المخيم في الجنينه المدينه في البلد مش في
المخيم نحن منفصل بين منطقه جنين المدين
او البلد انه قبل كم اسابيع
بلشت او بدات تشتغل
هذه هذه العمليه
وابعادها من وجهات نظرك
السؤال ممتاز المشكله وانت اذا كنت في
سؤالك في بدايه الحديث انه المشكله
المركزيه تبع الجيش والمقابرات
الاسرائيليه في مخيم جنين هو هي عفوا
المحاولات لاطلاق ونجاح
منهم
من على الشمال اسرائيل
وهذه التهديد من ناحيه اسرائيليه ما في اي
امكانيه
لاسماح او انه يشتغل تسمح لهذه الزهره انه
تمشي
وريح في منطقه من منطقه جنين نحن اليوم او
حتى اليوم كانت اكثر من خمسه وسته
المحاولات لاطلاق صواريخ من منطقه جنين
سواء بشكل الابتدائي على الشمال اسرائيل
لا مش مستوطنه على داخل
الخط الاخضر داخل
منطقه عفوله
واجبال الجلبوع معناته ان احنا بنحكي على
داخل اسرائيل في اي نقاش على هذا الموضوع
واسرائيل بتسمحش لحالها انه زهره
بغلاف غزه
من كتاب غزه ترجعك كمان مره في من الضفه
او من شمال لدفه داخل اسرائيل عشان هيك
راح لازم لازم نحكي بصراحه واسرائيل
التفاوضات بين سلطه فلسطينيه اسرائيل
وامريكا بعد نقشوها خلال
الخشد اللي كان في عكبه وكذا كانت تحكي
على عوده الاجهزه الفلسطينيه الفلسطينيه
لكل
المناطقيه وكمان تشمل مخيم جني السلطه
الفلسطينياء والسلطه الفلسطينياء
وحساباتها عندها ما اخذت الفرصه بشكل كامل
وما كان تشتغل داخل المخيم لسه الفوسا
موجوده
مفتوح بس السلطه
من افضليه
ضيوفنا ولكن هل التزامن هل هناك اي مغزى
لهذا التزامن مع قرار انشاء جدار على
الحدود الشرقيه من الاردن بدعوه مواجهه
حركه التسلل تسلل المهاجرين الافارقه هل
لهذا التزامن اي مغزى
انا انا شايف انه المشكله المشكله تسريبات
الاسلحه من من
[موسيقى]
لدفه وكمان للداخل الاسرائيلي هاي الزهيره
خطيره خطيره لسلطه خطيره خطيره كمان عشان
هيك نحن سمعنا رئيس الحكومه عفوا خلال
الايام الاخيره انه
الحكومه الاسرائيلي معلش من يصدق او يقتنع
انه التسلل عبر الحدود الاردنيه
المؤطره تاطيرا امنيا قويا وشديدا يمكن ان
تحدث عبره عمليات تسلل كما تقول
تسلل الاسلحه من الاردن لدفه بتاثر بشكل
سلبي جدا على كميه الاسلحه والاستخدام
الاسلحه المشكله داخل الضفه الغربيه
ومنطقه جنين
الى حدود ما اذن نصف ساعه مع سيارات مش
كثير من هيك وكمان
التاثير هو داخل اسرائيل كمان داخل
المجتمع العربي معناته انه احنا بنحكي على
ظهره خطيره جدا وتوصيل
خلال الشهور الاخيره هذه على بناء جدار في
هذا القدر شكرا لك
ونستقبل ضيفين الان من طول كرم الدكتور
حسن خريشه نائب رئيس المجلس التشريع
الفلسطيني ومن عمان سمير الحبشنه وزير
الداخليه والثقافه الاردنيه الاسبق اهلا
بكما وارداماك كيف وفي اي سياق يفهم هذا
التصعيد
يعني اولا هذه هي المره الثانيه التي يدخل
الاحتلال مره اخرى الى جنين كان ذلك قبل
شهرين من الان وفشل هذا الاحتلال للوصول
الى غايته وتحقيق اهدافه اليوم كمان دخل
مره اخرى وافشل هذا الدخول مره اخرى عبر
هذه المقاومه الموحده التي تعلم ما تريد
لديها جهاز استخبارات
جيد تقرا الاحداث هي موحده ميدانيا
وبالتالي تم افشال هذه العمليه مره اخرى
وبالتالي الاسرائيليين الان بعيشوا ازمه
حقيقيه هناك ازمه مجتمعيه وانقسام داخلي
داخل المجتمع الصهيوني وبالتالي يريد ان
يعكس ذلك بانتصار ولو كان بسيطا في مخيم
جنين او في اي منطقه اخرى بهذا العالم
سواء كان على المستوى العسكري في جنين او
على المستوى السياسي في تطبيعه مع احد
الدول اكبر الدول العربيه مثلا مع
السعوديه او غيرها وبالتالي هذا الامر قد
حسم هذه المره وبالتالي وافشل هذا
الاجتياح بالمناسبه هناك ايضا كانت هناك
تفاهمات ما بين السلطه الفلسطينيه وما بين
الاسرائيليين
نتائج اجتماعات كان في شرم الشيخ في
العقبه ثم في شرم الشيخ بحضور امريكي وغير
ذلك تحت عنوان التهدئه وبالتالي افشل نعم
افشل هذا الموضوع كمان مره من قبل هؤلاء
المقاومين وافشلوا الاحتلال الذي لم يلتزم
يوما من الايام باي اتفاق او تفاهمات
يتوقع او تقال مع السلطه الفلسطينيه على
اعتبار انه يريد لهذه السلطه ان تكون بشكل
علني تعمل مع هذا الاحتلال ولا يكتفي فقط
بالتنسيق الامني اي بمعنى عندما تدخل قوات
الاحتلال قوات الاجهزه الامنيه الفلسطينيه
للاسف الشديد تدخل الى مقراتها وشاهدنا
ذلك ويشاهد بام العين كل مع كل حدث
وبالتالي هذه الرساله للسلطه الفلسطينيه
انه انتم لستم مؤهلين للحفاظ على الامن
الفلسطيني بالرغم من اجراءات السلطه
المتعدده سواء كانت عبر اعتقالات كثيره
لمقاومين فلس
تجديد قبضتها او يدها الثقيله على
المقاومين وعلى حتى اصحاب الراي ومع ذلك
هذا هذا لا يكفي الاحتلال ولم يكتفي
الاحتلال بذلك وبالتالي هو اراد ان ياخذ
الامر على عاتقه هذه المره وايضا فشل لانه
حقيقه يعني بشعر الاحتلال انه لاول مره في
الضفه الغربيه يتم استنساخ تجربه غزه
بمعنى ان هناك كتيبه العياش وهي بالمناسبه
تطلق تسميه على البطل
العياش الذي استشهد في عام 95 96 وبالتالي
هؤلاء اصبح هناك اطلاق لصواريخ وبالتالي
هذه التجربه يعني حقيقه تصيب الاحتلال
هستيريا كبيره وبالتالي هذا الاجراء الذي
تم اتخاذه هذا اليوم من دخول
الى مخيم جنين واعتقال اثنين بعد يعني
اصابتهم بجروح خطيره وتم اعتقالهم لكن
البقيه المقاتلين لم يتمكن الاحتلال من
اصابه اي منهم وبالتالي لم يتمكن من اعت
قال احد منهم وبالتالي افشل هذا الموضوع
والذي وحده شعبنا ووحده ادواتنا
ننتقل الى الاستاذ سمير حبشنه على ماذا
تراهن حكومه نتنياهو بمثل هذه الممارسات
التي تتكرر كالعاده بين الحين
والاخر هل يمكن تفسير ما يحدث بالسياق
الامني فقط
مساء الخير استاذه خديجه مساء الخير استاذ
حسن في طول كرم العزيزه يعني انا اول شيء
استمعت
للاسرائيلي وهي روايه التدليس والتزييف
واخراج الامور عن السياق
التاريخي والهدف الرئيسي لما يجري في
الضفه الغربيه القضيه قضيه احتلال استاذه
خديجه هذا احتلال ليخرج الاحتلال ينتهي
الموضوع
ما دام في احتلال امام شعب يمتلك اراده
البقاء ومصر على الحياه فالمقاومه
باشكالها المختلفه تتجدد يعني الشعب
الفلسطيني اللي اشترح لتحرر العالمي في
الثمانين في اخر الثمانينات فكره
الانتفاضه الاولى هو قادر الجيل الالفيه
الثانيه اللي الان بيقوم في مقاومه
الاحتلال انا تقديري سواء كان الدخول الى
جنين او الحديث
عن
سميتها الجدران مع الجدار مع لبنان الجدار
مع الضفه الغربيه الجدار الجدار حقيقه هي
عقليه معقده عقليه مريضه عقليه من يقود
اسرائيل سيره الجدار وقد كان الون تحدث
عنها الون ابيتار بانه
لمواجهه تسلل وتسريب الاسلحه عبر الحدود
مع الاردن غير ذلك اي حد يمكن ان يقتنع
المرء بهذه المبررات علما ان الحدود
الاردنيه معروف انها من اشد الحدود تاطيرا
من الناحيه الامنيه
استاذه خديجه احنا حدودنا بحمد الله عنا
يقضى امنيه وفي عنا قوات المسلحه على كل
الحدود من الشمال والجنوب والغرب
حدود يعني امن صارم وقوي هذه حجاج تعبر عن
عقليه الكيتو هؤلاء لما كانوا في اوروبا
كنت كما تعليمه كانوا يعيشوا باحياء مغلقه
فيعني حاله الرعب مسكونين في الرعب الخوف
من الاخر
بدفعهم الى هذه الاجراءات الغير انسانيه
الانسان بطبيعته كان اجتماعي لكن هؤلاء
ناس منغلقين وجاء اليمين هذا المتشدد انا
بسميهم دواعش الدين اليهودي هم الحكام في
اسرائيل اليوم هم الحكام الدواعش اليوم
هؤلاء لا يفهموا الا هذه العقليه عقليه
اغلق على نفسك
تحصن الاخر دائما ضدك وهذه اوامر ساده
خديجه امور لن تجدي هذا الشعب الفلسطيني
شعب ينظر الى هدف رئيسي وهو حريته وانعتاق
وقيام دولته وهذا سوف يتم اليوم او غدا
سوف يتم الان الاسرائيليين يعني بيسعوا
الى قصه انه بيعملوا هنا وهناك تطبيع
استاذه خديجه التطبيع مع الشعوب
الاتفاقيه الاردنيه عمرها 30 سنه
الاتفاقيه المصريه اربعين سنه اين هو
التطبيع مع الشعب
زياره عفوا وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي الى
البحرين
والمسلسل مستمر
استاذه خديجه اربعين سنه مع مصر و30 سنه
مع الاردن اين هو التطبيع هل يستطيع واحد
يقول انا اسرائيلي يسير في شوارع عمان او
في شوارع القاهره حقيقه انه اذا لم يتم
التطبيع مع العرب يتم اذا ما اخذوا الشعب
الفلسطيني حقوقهم خلاف ذلك سوف يبقى هذا
الصراع مستعر وسوف ياتي يوم تختل في
موازين القوى الامن المجرد استاذه خديجه
تاريخيا لا يحل الاشكاليات بين الشعوب
الامن الهند قال احتلت حررها غاندي والشعب
الهندي بالنظال السلبي بالسكوت بالصمت انا
اعتقد انه كل اجراءاتهم دوله منفعله عصابه
منفعله يمين داعشه متطرف لا يرى الاخر
عنصري عصابي شوفي انت شوفي اشكالهم لما
يطلعوا الوزراء الاسرائيليين هذول الجدد
ناس عصابيين بتحسوا واحد مري بده علاج في
في مستشفى انا بعتقد استاذه خديجه ما يجري
في جنينه بخلاصه ما اريد ان اقوله ما يجري
في جنين وغير جنين سوف لا يؤدي العنف الا
الى عنف مكافئ والعنف الاول عنف ظالم
والعنف والعنف الثاني هو عنف مشروع لانه
كما قلت وهنا تحول الى الاستاذ حسن خريشه
ما يجري في جنين وغير جنين يدفع المشهد
الى اين خصوصا ان المقاومه اشارتي الى ان
الهدف ابعد من مجرد القبض على
مطلوبين لاسرائيل وان الهدف هو الضرب
المقاومه في الضفه الغربيه وكسر الى ذاتها
كما كما تقول كيف ترى هذا الامر
انا اولا منذ اكثر من عامين والاحتلال
يعني يحاول جاهدا الاجتثاث المقاومه بشكل
كبير وهو شكل واضح لانه لاول مره تكون
لدينا يعني شكلت كتائب في كل المدن
الفلسطينيه بدات في شمال الضفه الغربي
وتحديدا في جنين ثم نابلس وهذه الكتائب
على اهميتها على رغم انها تختلف بعضها مع
الاخر عقائديا وسياسيا والى اخره لكنها
تتفق على مقاومه هذا المحتل وبالتالي
الاسرائيليين يسعوا دائما لاجهاض او
الاجتهاد هذه الظاهره لانه تشكل خطوره
كبيره واستنساخ كما قلت لتجربه غزه التي
بدات يعني ضعيفه ثم قويت واصبحت الان تهدد
يعني تستطيع ان تصنع معادله الرعب مع
الاحتلال هذا جانب الجانب الاخر
الاسرائيلي ينتشر في ذلك وبالتالي
استعانوا دائما كالعاده بادواتهم
واصدقائهم بالمنطقه جاء وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي ثم سي اي الامريكان وبعض اشقائنا
العرب للاسف الشديد جاؤوا تحت عنوان تهدئه
الاوضاع وبالتالي اخذت السلطه على عاتقها
حضور لهذه الاجتماعات التي تحدثنا عنها من
اجل تحت باب تهدئه لكن هي بالاساس تهدف
الي هو اجتماعات امنيه تهدف الى اجتثال
المقاومه هذه المقاومه بدات الان يعني كما
قلت تنتشر في كل الارض الفلسطينيه في
الضفه الغربي تحديدا وراينا كيف انه
فلسطيني واحد يستطيع بعمليه عسكريه فدائيه
ان يفشل كل المؤتمرات التي تعقد من اجل
اجتاز هذه المقاومه راينا ذلك في حواره
راينا ذلك في الخليل راينا ذلك بالقدس وفي
عقبه تبرك في كل المنطقه وبالتالي لم
تستطع الاسرائيليين انهاء هذه الظاهره ولن
يستطيعوا وايضا يعني خلينا نقول النخبه
السياسيه المتنفذه في الساحه الفلسطينيه
والتي تعقد مثل هكذا ايضا هي الاخرى لا
تستطيع فعل اي شيء في هذا الموضوع
السياسيا ما خياراتها
الان كل ما يجري
للاسف هي خيارات هي هي الان امام مرحله
تاريخيه يعني مفصليه اما ان تلتحق وتشكل
غطاء او على الاقل ده شكل الغطاء للمقاومه
على الاقل ان تترك او ترفع يدها الثقيله
عن المقاومه والمقاومين هذا مهم وان تطلق
سراح كل المعتقلين وتحديدا المقاومين منهم
الاجانب لانه حقيقه هي تعزل نفسها بنفسها
من خلال هذه التفاهمات وايضا المقاومه
كلما اشتدت تعزل هذه السلطه نحن نريد لهذه
السلطه ان تبقى لكن تقدم خدمات
للفلسطينيين لكن ان لا يعيشوا على وهم
الوهم اللي عشنا عليه سنوات طويل في
امكانيه تحقيق تسويه في ظل هذه الاوضاع هم
يدركوا تماما انه العالم يتحرك عندما يعني
تكون اسرائيل مهزومه او بحاله ازمه
وبالتالي هم لا ياتوا للشعب الفلسطيني
ويتحدثوا عن شعب فلسطين ولا عن حقوق الشعب
الفلسطيني وبالتالي اليوم الاسرائيلي نفسه
ازمتهم بدهم ينكسوها من خلال هذه
المواجهات العسكريه وهذه العسكري
ايضا نتنياهو يبحث عن نصر صغير من خلال
اصراره والامريكان على تطبيع مع السعوديه
للاسف الشديد نحن الفلسطينيين للاسف اول
من طبع لانه نحن نتحمل مسؤوليه كل التطبيق
الذي جرى في عالمنا العربي الذي بدا
بالخليج وفي مقوله الهيكل قال يوم من
الايام انه يعني لن يجروا احد على التطبيق
مع الاسرائيليين الا اذا وافقت مصر او
شاركت وسبطت السعوديه اليوم المصريين
النظام الرسمي المصري هو مطبع وايضا
سعوديه الان في طريقه للتطبيع لكن تحت
دعوات انهم يريدوا قبل التطبيع شروطا وهذه
الشروطا انا بعتقد لن يحصلوا على شيء منها
وانما هي مبررات جاء الوفد الفلسطيني
الشديد
اليوم يذهب الى السعوديه للقاء الامريكان
لطرح موضوعات يعني حتى نكون نحن مسيرين او
جسر للتطبيع مع هؤلاء تقابل اموال تقدم
لنا مقابل شرط ان تعيد امريكا
مكتب منظمه التحرير واشنطن وبالتالي احنا
الان بنعيش ازمه وهذه النخبه المتنفذه
تشعر
هذا كله يقودنا هذا الكلام يقودنا الى
السؤال والسؤال لسم الاستاذ سمير الحبشنه
عن التاثير
المرتقب فيما يتعلق بمسار التهدئه وما
يستند اليه من تفاهمت امنيه وقد اشرت
اليها قبل قليل اضافه الى مسار التطبيع
الجاري مع عدد من الدول العربيه
يعني سيدتي في موضوع التطبيع انا اتمنى
حقيقه الان السعوديه دوله ذات دوله مركز
في الوطن العربي دوله قويه بكل ما تعني
الكلمه على الصعيد الاقليمي والدولي
والمحلي انا بتمنى على يعني اشقائنا في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
يعني ان يبقوا على نفس الموقف اللي اعلنه
سمو ولي العهد وهو ان لا تطبيع الا بقيام
الدوله الفلسطينيه وعاصمتها القدس وهذا هو
العنوان اللي الاشقاء السعوديين للان هذا
اللي اعلن فانتمنى حقيقه لان السعوديه كما
ذكرت دوله مهمه جدا ليس كباقي الدول
وموقفها يحسب وموقفها مؤثر في الحياه
العربيه والحياه الفلسطينيه تحديدا سيدتي
انا
كشخص عربي
يرى فلسطين يشهد يرى المشهد الفلسطيني من
الخارج انا بعتقد انه ليس من الخطا ان
نتحدث مع الاخر مع ونعطي وجه مدني ونعطي
وجه ان العرب وان الفلسطينيين يودون
السلام على قاعده الدولتين والانعتاق
وانهاء الاحتلال وبنفس الوقت بخط موازي
الجناح الاخر هو جناح الشبيب المقاوم في
فلسطين انا ادعو استاذه خديجه في النهايه
ادعو شعبنا العربي الفلسطيني وقوال حيه
الى انهاء الانقسام والاتفاق على برنامج
وطني فلسطيني مرحله يعيد وحده الشعب
الفلسطيني الجغرافي الفلسطينيه لانه
الفلسطينيين
سيدتى الوقت ادركنا انا بقول الخاسر اللي
بتوجعنا اليوم هي الانقسام الفلسطيني
هذا البرنامج شكرا جزيلا لكما من عمان
الاستاذ سمير الحبشه وزير داخلها الثقافه
الاردني الاسبق وضيفنا من طولكرم الدكتور
حسن خريشه نائب رئيس المجلس التشريعي
الفلسطيني شكرا لكما وبهذا ناتي الى ختام
هذه الحلقه من برنامج الخبر لكم منا اطيب
المنى والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]